je crois pas quand y'a pas d'actions
judiciaires ont dit la justice n'est pas
indépendante quand il y en a certains
s'en plaignent mois et coûté à debout la
france ya pas de casseroles à debout la
france on a des propositions
j'étais le sol dans l'hémicycle quand
même ya quinze jours et j'ai pas vu les
députés républicains de monsieur fillon
j'ai pas vu les députés front national
pour voter le casier judiciaire vierge
pour se présenter aux élections
tiens il y avait pas grand monde en été
vains et il a fallu même se battre
contre le gouvernement donc moi je fais
des propositions je suis candidat
différent parce que je suis un homme
politique profondément différent d'eux
j'ai rompu avec eux il ya dix ans j'ai
pris mes risques
j'ai ramé il ya de plus en plus de
français qui me soutiennent c'est
beaucoup plus dur que pour les autres on
me demande dix fois plus d'efforts pour
voir le même temps de parole j'en suis à
100 fois moins de temps de parole et je
suis convaincu qu'à une voix pour la
france et 2 donc de 7,2 c'est moi je
veux proposer des choses différentes aux
français mais c'est tout après des
français jugent mais de fait dans le
débat public en scène en rien ses
affaires judiciaires pour vous la
justice ne doit pas s'arrêter mais elles
doivent accélérer avant les élections et
elle ne doit pas s'arrêter
la seule remarque je fais c'est que si
la justice très n'est pas tant au fil de
l'année
peut-être qu'ils se réveillent mais
moins vite au dernier moment qu'est ce
que j'aimerais c'est que la justice elle
passe naturellement et qu'elles soient
pas si longue parce que le problème
judiciaire français que ce soit
d'ailleurs pour le petit délinquant ou
délinquants en col blanc c'est qu'on
attend des années et que comme on attend
des années on sait jamais où on en est
et ça profite aux gros et ce que j'ai
trouvé scandaleux c'est le vote le vote
qui a eu lieu où la prescription des
délits financiers a été arrangé par le
monde politique et financier tout
récemment c'est quand même extravagant
ce qui s'est passé c'est à dire que la
prescription a été allongée pour les
crimes et les délits et pour les délits
financiers les alors là ça a été remis
au point de départ et non au point de
deux naissances de l'infraction est pas
à la découverte
alors on sait que vous êtes à des clones
sommes un peu gonflé de la part de
certains on
impressions juste fini on appris